[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
isabelle morini bosc qui va passer le
permis de conduire qui a peut-être gagné
son permis de conduire elle un parcours
à faire isabelle morini-bosc on va
revoir le parcours
jérôme revon elle a une baignoire au
dessus de la voiture il ya de l'eau qui
va tomber
non mais si l'eau passe en dessous du
niveau voilà de la bande rouge perdu
pour le permis elle joue pour la perdre
pour elle et elle joue pour quelqu'un
qu'on appelle tout de suite aussi est-ce
que vous êtes prête isabelle ouais elle
était mal
comme vous pouvez le constater la sodam
et aimable tu peux juste prévenir le
personnel d'airtel à 4 heures du matin
s'il risque vont arriver une année avec
un pool de sexisme à 3 grammes elle
s'appelle comment elle s'appelle votre
votre pote d'auto école elle s'appelle
audrey à oui voilà j'avais déjà oublié
son prénom adresse et tu prenais les
pédalos mot bas j'ai c'est que non mais
bon allez on y va vous l'avez expliqué
comment conduire pas du tout on a passé
tout le temps à régler son os google
maps rennes ça va c'est beau bassin
petite ola moyens allez on y va
c'est parti on y va
bon allez
ne mettez pas les animaux entre sa
structure et ça ça suffit comme ça pas
les animaux par les animaux c'est sinon
pour l'instant ça va s'cauet
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
on regardera les collèges à melbourne et
des restaurants de locaux instance et
gagne perd bien vite je viens du volant
alors occupés s'est pas fait c'est
d'aller tourner tout mais la prod de
taco bell au goût de la musique amazighe
arrêter la musique à l'ère qu'on les
entende alors isabelle côté entourée de
mystère à les appelle comme toi on va
jusqu'au chalet je dis stop
mais tu sais que je fermais concurrencé
par d'autres soit clair dans ma tête
soit au volant juste la tête elles ont
peu plus de volume à eybens et l'argent
menad ont brûlé tout va mal je prenne
pied du palais sur comprennent pas alors
c'est plus rare si tu ne fais pas tu
utilises le froid comme tu veux pour que
le long de l'arête avant de faire et
quand même toujours
[Rires]
3 à leur honneur revient au point de
départ
bref on renault poids des ports on y va
alors marche à aller voir d'un point de
presse à kaboul aux gémonies et vit pour
l'instant saccadé dans la saga des par
ici par ici la voile et si tu veut taxer
leurs apportons avec peu vite parce que
là il ya trop de bordel là haut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez pas encore
on a tous d'accord
attendez
[Applaudissements]
on va vérifier les chéris si le permier
gagner a priori c'est bob tahri et
jessica également je suis catalan a
connu un match évident que c'était un
vrai lit je veux qu est-ce qui la caisse
qu'il a atteint alors là les abel oui
vous avez gagné le permis de conduire bt
à l'e10 dont jamais jamais conduit elle
est partie un poil est revenue
[Applaudissements]
kubel et bedous celle là elle a voulu la
prendre donoma pour la conduite elle est
revenue sur à l'aise en union pétard
mouillé
un truc de ouf la pauvre monsieur
monitrice a pas je m attendais à mardi
soir
ah bon
alors voilà micro alors qu'est ce qu'il
pense a dévoilé mardi s'y coller audrey
bartier bonjour comment ça va bien ça va
alors la santé attendez attendez sur le
poisson saab en dressage et navré je
suis désolé elle a bien compris
ben je suis pas sûr il a dit je rêve
mais si jolie nous titre non-payés gêne
au titre je vous en ai je vous offre
votre permis de conduire
vous savez vous pouvez vous le carré
[Musique]